bartz suave quem fala é o dado que seja
muito bem vindo já mais um vídeo e o
extrato de que levaria o anjo próprios
ritos em que o jogo né e vai pessoal eu
já sei o que me espera porque já tem a
ver algumas coisas sombrias de jogo e eu
tenho certeza que vai ser o pior jogo
que eu vou jogar na minha vida que suste
eu não quero sair ele não quer jogar
pertinho bosco embora lá não precisa
tirar o fone não precisa sempre aí é
hoje pessoal eu acho que vou jogar com
ele o meu vilson - já assusta andré vai
enviar mesmo e não sei como é que começa
a estudar esta semana duas tardes não
começa por que a áfrica não tô dentro do
jogo assim vai sim vai ser maior já que
o sul registrou ai meu deus é o demônio
já é o demônio mexer senão quando chove
o caixa está mais real do convênio que
eu vi
ai meu deus vai por ser agora um homem
paixão está pagando é fugir mesmo a
sério está está muito inchado militar
também é real não é tudo uma faca em
caixa onde ocorre o pai acredita que
mesmo com as scut né meu deus como cuba
e muco muco a eu olhava imprimir meu
olhar pra mim e eu não consegui ser o
único concelho vai te embora isso vá
embora
vai lá e pronto pronto pronto soube é
que eu só vi te que tudo o que vai
acontecer agora é surpresa pra mim uma
mulher a então lista
ai ta ai mãe de alex tosa nem campeão
ai ai agora a não não não basta o
campeão não que eu preciso de uma
tesoura aí eu estou sentindo é o tamanho
dela para os cães no fígado da minha
filha só para o país mas é preciso que a
idéia não não queriam nem um campeão não
é tão gordo o fundo é que ela vai fazer
mal nenhum não os petistas não eu vou
estar no olho
aí o que ocorreu tudo bem tudo bem tudo
bem eu acho que toda aquela [ __ ] na
boca explodiu
não sei o que aconteceu num curto
discurso ailton andré terá não que
acreditava puxar - que entrara puxava e
ainda não consegui nada pra trazer um
novo olhar para trás um culto o estouro
como câmera cama desde o mês de janeiro
ainda não não só seja eu vou chorar o
ministro vai precisar do mesmo estava
pesado meu amor né pessoas mortas aqui
ayotte plantel estar porque colégio do
trote para trás da chatuba
eu vejo as minhas pernas mix tosos eu
não sei se sou homem mas furou mas há
muito o coração na boca
normalmente têm luz né
não vou pra onde eu sou uma fã que
mulher faz da perna o homem não tem esta
perna e testar em seres humanos reais
meu deus olha aí um homem gordo calma
calma calma calma para o que está a
fazer valer a desculpa não chegou do
senhor sergento está à procura do que eu
sou uma [ __ ] outra vez aqui do lado
ai ai meu coração
ae o que é isto
talvez um homem o gum
até que os maquinistas matou animais né
meu deus eu não vou tirar a limpo não
quero ficar discutindo coisas do sol já
não sei o que quero dizer que já fiz
merda
tá nem por quê questionou o meu deus o
que para ele não faz parte direta vai
ser frente da frente na hora que eu não
consigo andar para trás está tudo escuro
o jogo seguiu na frente da porta
ai ai o que é muito perigoso cair o que
ele provou que ir mas não esteve à
altura e vertigens - fernão aiai
o primeiro é o docente chão do quarto e
primeiro é meu deus e agora vai haver
alguma coisa no chão né
eu consigo na mesma prova a chuva alguma
coisa do chão meu que ficou tudo escuro
do demônio é baixo e está enxergando a
taxa de água
o sangue não sai por aí eu trouxe um
treinador - meu deus eu fui um estômago
- eu vou conseguir comer big macs o
monstro
a hitachi uma água esquisita água preta
está agora em um inferno
segundo informações o fogo né
o que as pessoas dizem alga carvalho
aqui também
ai ai eu tenho que me pego meu tempo nem
eu percebi não vai perturbar o mesmo da
outra vez no outro jogo por si muito
branda é grande não perceberam ak mim é
uma será em meu deus é um povo pelo
homem
ae mas por favor não quero fazer amor
vai estar ou não
eu sei que o história mas não assim não
chega de sangue não meu ela tem qualquer
desculpa não torre ter não por favor não
faça esmalte não pára
para mim é um elo oito novas dentre os
planos de fazer o favor de um que eu vou
por favor eu não quer mais registra
gastos não acho que o meu deus meu deus
meu deus me eu sobrevivi
esta foi a melhor experiência de terror
que os ganhe alguma vez nos jogos
invicta sério está cada vez fica mais
real mas é isso pessoal como ela foi que
foi bonito ver quem vai até a próxima